je voudrais me présenter devant vous
avec beaucoup d'humilité parce qu'à côté
des monstres régionaux qui existent
aujourd'hui avec 3 4 5 millions
d'habitants et plus bon la corse avec
ses 320 mille habitants fait figure de
parent pauvre en tout cas faible
démographiquement
mais quand on dit faible
démographiquement ça veut dire aussi
faible économiquement humilité aussi
parce que nous n'avons pas le privilège
d'être élu dans des conditions normales
pour six ans comme vous tous mais en
raison des contraintes qui nous ont été
imposées par le gouvernement nous
l'assemblée de corse ne sera élu que
pour deux ans jusqu'à la fin 2009 110 de
et cela parce que le gouvernement dans
la loi notre imposer une règle du jeu
que qui n'a été consenti par personne
pas de consultation référendaire comme
ça a été le cas en alsace et depuis
cette consultation
on se méfie mais une au détour d'un
article de la loi notre et bien on a dit
à partir du 1er janvier 2018 il sera
situé une collectivité unique encore ce
qui veut dire que les deux départements
seront supprimés au moment même où les
préfets en corse organise le découpage
des intercommunalités dans des
conditions tout à fait ordinaire et sans
tenir compte de l'absence totale de
département à compter du 1er janvier
2018 donc c'est une mesure imposée c'est
une mesure de contrainte et nous allons
mobiliser l'opinion insulaire pour faire
en sorte que nous soyons demain
majoritaire à l'assemblée de corse pour
que la négociation sur les ordonnances
qui seront soumise pour avis à
l'assemblée de corse soit faite entre
une majorité de la droite et du centre
et un gouvernement socialiste car si
demain les socialistes et la gauche
était au pouvoir à l'assemblée de corse
le gouvernement écrivant les ordonnances
avec une ratification par le parlement
qui serait une ratification de routine
eh bien je doute de la qualité de ceux
qui seraient
réaliser donc je vous demande de de
croûtes de croire que nous avons la
volonté de gagner non seulement pour
cela mais aussi parce que nous voulons
que la corsa et mieux pendant cinq
années de gestion de gauche et nous
allons triste privilège d'avoir non
seulement un président d'exécutif
radical socialiste de gauche mais un
président de l'assemblée de corse comme
nice parce que nous nous avons deux
présidents depuis le statut de 1992 avec
un équilibre des pouvoirs d'ailleurs qui
peut être intéressant comme une
préfiguration de l'avenir pour deux
grandes régions mais en tout cas cette
majorité de gauche un bilan calamiteux
dans la mesure où le chômage a augmenté
de 60% pendant cette période c'est le
taux d'augmentation du chômage le plus
important de france le taux de pauvreté
est fixé aujourd'hui à 19% alors qu'en
moyenne au plan national il est
d'environ 14% et surtout la croissance
qui avait été relativement importante
plus importante que dans les autres
régions pendant la période précédente où
la droite a gouverné et bien est
aujourd'hui en berne et est relativement
étales
donc il faut que nous reprenions
l'initiative et tout ce qui a été dit au
niveau des propositions d'acide à sion
développement économique nous faisons
ces propositions notre évidemment dans
la mesure où au moment où les emplois
publics par définition vont se tasser se
stabiliser voire régresser dans
certaines situations
la seule chance de notre île c'est
évidemment une croissance économique
pour l'emploi beaucoup plus forte et des
initiatives avec une corse qui doit
rester une corse ouverte fraternelle qui
se situe dans notre pays qui est un pays
ouvert qui se situent en europe et qui
recevant des visiteurs et des touristes
du monde entier se doit d'être
accueillante pour présenter son image la
plus favorable et faire en sorte que
l'identité corse comme l'identité
bretonne où l'identité alsacienne et
celle des autres aussi des autres
régions
et bien soit une identité qui attire une
identité ouverte et non pas une identité
repliée sur elle-même
face à un mouvement indépendantiste qui
a marqué la vie politique insulaire
pendant des années et qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui régressé pour défendre la
république
merci beaucoup